three years ago we organized the Nexus
conference entitled the triumph of
science and we also had people from the
world of transhumanism and I was
fascinated by the fact that based on a
pretty pessimistic view on human nature
they think that due to the technology we
are having we should improve human
beings with this technology because the
world is too dangerous drawn in the
nuclear weapons and to make sure that
the tragedies will not happen we should
use new technology to improve human
nature what do you think about that I'm
very skeptical a personal and skeptical
that we need to re-engineer humans to
achieve peace Canada and the United
States have not fought a war since the
war of 1812 and no one had to
re-engineer Canadians or Americans the
Netherlands and that Germany have not
fought a Wars in more than 70 years we
did not have to genetically engineer the
Dutch there are many changes to our
institutions and our norms and our ideas
that can reduce or eliminate the risks
of nuclear war without what I consider a
rather quixotic attempt to change the
course of human evolution I'm also on
purely scientific grounds highly
skeptical of the prophecy that we will
reengineer human nature I think that
these predictions came in the during the
brief burst of enthusiasm for finding
the gene for intelligence the gene for
altruism and so on we now know that
there is no such gene
there are hundreds or thousands of genes
each of which increments or decrements
psychological traits by a tiny amount to
genetically engineer someone you would
not a matter of sticking it one gene
you'd have to replace thousands of genes
we have no idea how to do that we're not
going to know how to do
anytime soon and we also don't know how
many of those jeans might lead to an
improvement in one aspect and a risk in
another aspect there may be a gene that
increases your IQ by two thirds of a
point but also increases your chances of
getting brain cancer or bipolar disorder
by a third of a point and there it's
gonna be a very long time if ever until
we know how to balance those tiny
benefits and tiny risks multiplied by
hundreds or thousands of genes so I'm
purely scientific grounds I doubt that
it will happen and then on historical
grounds I don't think we need it what
will be your choice what is it that you
think is essential to make sure that in
whatever form quote-unquote we can save
the world we have to first of all have
an empirical mindset you were right
there are many hypotheses we have to
look to see which ones have made the
world better and which ones have made
the world worse I think the track record
of messiahs is not particularly good I
think there's a excellent reason to
believe that there's no such thing as a
messiah and there never will be on the
other hand there are some things that
they do work international institutions
like the United Nations has decreased
the probability of war it has eliminated
war but it's made it less likely we have
reason to believe that trade and
cosmopolitanism the movement of people
and ideas has been a positive force the
reason to think that democracy has more
advantages than disadvantages and I
think the what we have to do is not
believe that we can deduce what will
make the world better from first
principles and then impose them and in
full confidence that we know how the
world is going to react because we don't
we're not that smart but we really have
to look at our past track record track
record look at the data what makes
things what makes people better off what
makes people worse off now the
conference it will be the weekend of the
American elections will you still say
the same things if mr. Trump will be the
next president of America I think it's
extremely unlikely and all the
indicators are
that he will not be at the next
president if he is president I think
that that would be a definitely negative
development and there's there's no
guarantee that in all positive trends
such as the trend toward tolerance
cosmopolitanism democracy knowledge
guided decision-making will continue
there's no there's no iron laws that
propel the world in a particular
direction
there are contingent events that are
unpredictable so bad things could happen
how bad could it be much depends
that is if Trump were elected much
depends on how much a single man can
control the entire apparatus of American
government
fortunately American government has some
checks and balances built in there are
there's the Supreme Court there's the
legislators there's local governments
and state governments and just the
willingness or reluctance of the
American people to go along with
particular policies so as long as Trump
doesn't become the Fuhrer with or like
Mao with absolute control and I think
that's that's not likely then the worst
case scenarios probably will not happen
but then from being elected is itself a
worst case scenario that I think will
probably not happen okay which bank and
we are firmly looking forward to me to
again after them